now that we've started exploring the
occult sciences more broadly and been
given a general overview of the occult
sciences in the islamic world in
particular we can start to dive deeper
into these particular subjects we've
already talked about talismans and
magical objects and today we're going to
be talking about one of the most popular
fields within occult sciences in all of
history the science of the heavenly
bodies their behaviors effects and
uses that is otherwise known as
astrology
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now this is a very special collaboration
with my friend dr angela puka and her
channel angela symposium she will be
making a video on astrology in 20th
century western esotericism which fits
very well with this video that i'm doing
here today so after you watch this video
you should definitely go check out hers
as well as subscribe to her channel dr
puka is a phd and university lecturer
who focuses on all things occult
esoteric things like shamanism and
astrology for example so she's really an
expert on all these topics and i highly
recommend her channel i'll leave a link
to that video and to her channel in the
description and in a pinned comment
in the early 14th century the famous
hanbali theologian and jurist ibn
taymiyah condemned the practice of
astrology as impermissible for muslims
and as a dangerous pseudoscience
many other figures such as the historian
ibn khaldoon followed a similar line of
arguments
indeed astrology was always one of the
most controversial of occult sciences in
the islamic world
while scholarly opinions on these
sciences varied and were quite complex
from a general perspective it was always
a controversial matter to some
and astrology was one of the most widely
condemned its critics argue that by
giving powers over our lives to the
heavenly bodies we are divesting power
from god thus making it akin to
polytheism regardless of this
controversy astrology was truly
widespread in the islamic world it was
very popular among a wide spectrum of
people from the lower classes to the
kings and sultans and scholars as a way
of predicting events or in various
magical practices and some of the most
significant islamic philosophers who
dealt with astrology would have a major
impact on the later development of
occult sciences in europe and western
esotericism as well
astrology is a broad field with a long
history and we should of course be
careful to distinguish it from astronomy
usually astronomy is simply the study of
the heavenly bodies in a more general
sense determining their movements and
behavior etc and this was quite useful
in an islamic environment in order to
figure out things like prayer times or
the start and end of the month of
fasting
astrology on the other hand is the
science that posits that the heavenly
bodies and their movements have direct
effects on things on earth and for human
beings if you're born when jupiter and
saturn are in a certain position that
means this and that for your life and
that kind of thing
according to abu mahad it is quote the
knowledge of the nature of every planet
and sphere and the specifics of their
significations and what is born and what
occurs from the power of their diverse
motions and their effects on this
sub-learner world such as the difference
of the seasons the transformation of the
natures that are fire air water and
earth and the things that result from
these natures such as the genera of
animals plants and minerals and from
this first kind of science of these
stars astronomy that is a universal
science the second kind is inferred that
is the science of the judgments of the
stars
while the line between these two
categories was pretty unclear and fuzzy
in ancient times and medieval times of
course more so than they are today at
least the islamic thinkers do seem to
have made a pretty clear distinction
indeed there are very significant
islamic astronomers like ibn haitham and
al-farabi and even ibn cena that don't
seem to have been
great fans of astrology as such so it is
a complicated affair but again astrology
was widespread and very popular to many
it was completely compatible with islam
as a religion in arabic the term for
astrology used was
literally the science of the judgments
of the stars
but it of course existed since long
before the emergence of islam we know
that some of the most ancient
civilizations like the babylonians and
egyptians did significant astronomical
and astrological speculations
many of the greek and hellenic
philosophers such as the late platonist
were also hugely interested in this art
in the very heartland of islam in arabia
astrology was widespread in the
pre-islamic period it served as a
significant technique of divination and
might have been an important aspect of
religious practices here and the arabs
not only took these practices with them
as they expanded across the middle east
but also came into direct contact with
other flourishing astrological
traditions
also very significant to this story is
the mysterious community in haran in
modern turkey
these haranians seem to have been very
heavily into astronomy and astrology as
they are referred to as star worshipers
by muslim chroniclers as well as being
strongly influenced by hermeticism
perhaps as a result of this latter point
and the common islamic idea that
identifies hermes with the prophet idris
the haranians were often identified with
the sabians of the quran and thus seen
as among the so-called people of the
book or the kitab
the traditions of the haranians as well
as the other cultures and traditions of
the wider middle eastern region
influenced the early muslim community
and the philosophers and helped to
establish
astrology and astronomy as important
sciences
astrology was seen as an important
science to the abbasid calebs for
example as being very helpful in
predicting the outcomes of battles or
for military strategy and due to this
wide acceptance of astrology in the
early period many works were imported
and translated from places like india
persia and the regions that have already
been mentioned so how does astrology
work according to these scholars we will
begin by exploring the theories of some
of the earliest and most important
astrological figures in the islamic
world such as al kindy and all the way
to the very famous pikatrix but to do so
we also need to have some background
information about their general
cosmological worldview the essential
cosmology of this period was based on an
earlier greek model the geocentric model
of the universe as developed by ptolemy
was accepted as an established truth
with the earth or material world at the
center of the universe and then a group
of concentric spheres extending outwards
each sphere being associated with a
particular planet and its movement and
made out of a kind of non-material
ethereal substance
these planets were from the closest to
the earth to the farthest the moon
mercury venus the sun mars jupiter and
saturn
beyond this is the sphere of the zodiac
of the many stars in the sky as we know
them
aristotle seen as the prime philosopher
to the islamic thinkers was also a very
important figure in this regard for most
of the middle ages aristotle's natural
philosophy topped off with a little
neoplatonism was the basis for all of
these activities this included the
theory that the world was essentially
made up of the four elements water air
fire and earth as well as the
corresponding opposing characteristics
that are affected by them such as hot
versus cold wet versus dry much of these
systems of astrology are dependent on
this world view the ptolemaic geocentric
cosmology with a neoplatonism influenced
aristotelian natural philosophy
two of the earliest and most significant
figures in the development of astrology
in the islamic world are the polymath
al-khindi and the astrologer abu mashad
these two although differing on a number
of points would lay the groundwork for
most of the later tradition as well as
astrology in europe these philosophers
were devoted muslims and kindy spent
much of his writings arguing for the
compatibility of islam and these
sciences arguing that they are not only
compatible but mutually beneficial and
this included astrology in the quran it
states that quote in the creation of the
heavens and the earth in the rotation of
night and day are sure signs for those
people possessed of minds
to al-kindi and his peers this was an
indication that astrology or astronomy
was a legitimate science even encouraged
by god in the quran
the heavenly bodies contained signs of
god's work science that could be
interpreted and understood by those able
those possessed of minds
and that is what is at the essence of
astrology to these scholars the heavenly
bodies determine things here on earth
they can be used to foretell future
events they can affect our bodies our
moods and even change physical things we
can see this clearly in later magical
grimoires like the
hakim known in the west as the pikatrix
and in magical practice in general how
the planets and heavenly alignments
become central parts of magical
practices what is so significant about
thinkers like al-kindi and abu masad is
that they actually theorized about the
ways that these correspondences worked
it was clear to them that the heavenly
bodies had an effect on things here on
earth but how did this actually work
this is where al kindy is one of the
most significant figures in history
he's sometimes known as the first arabic
philosopher which is kind of a weird
title but from a perspective of the
islamic period he is definitely early
he hailed from the arabic kinder tribe
as his name suggests and spent much of
his life at the house of wisdom in
baghdad at the height of the abbasid
caliphate al-kindi was a true genius and
a polymath who was not only central in
the translation movement but mastered a
whole ocean of subjects himself on which
he wrote massive amounts of works he is
important for his contributions to
astrology as this episode suggests but
also in terms of theology optics
medicine mathematics and even music
theory all of which are often strongly
connected to each other of course
but in his astrological slash
astronomical writings he's perhaps most
remembered for his introduction of the
theory of stellar rays
developed in a treatise that has become
known simply as on the stellar rays
alcandi presents a theory of how the
heavenly bodies influence our world
below it was clear to al kindly and his
peers that everything in the world was
intimately connected possibly influenced
by the historic idea of sympathea
and this not only
includes the material world but also the
heavens so to al kindy he suggests that
the heavenly bodies and the stars so the
planets and everything
influence things down here through the
emanation of rays
the influence of the stars is
undoubtedly due to the rays sent from
them into the world
end quote
these rays are what determines and
creates all effects in the material
world
different rays and different
combinations of rays have different
effects and thus create the variety of
things that we can experience these rays
also give and sustain life through their
power this idea of the stellar rays is a
way for alkindi to propose a theory for
how astrology works
how the stars influence things in the
material world but it is primarily also
a way to explain the workings of magic
when one is doing magic one is simply
controlling and using the rays of the
heavens to affect things on earth
a talisman for example is made in
connection to a certain constellation or
planetary condition in order to capture
the powers or rays of that heavenly
event
in the words of the scholar lyanna saif
quote in essence astral magic is an act
of informing and ensouling that entails
harnessing the rays of planet stars and
constellations to charge an object that
is constructed according to a thorough
knowledge of correspondences between
celestial and terrestrial things
enabling the operator to organize the
elements of her practice towards a
specific purpose
elkind himself writes that quote all
different locations and times produce
different individual things in this
world
this is achieved by the heavenly harmony
all things receive rays from the heavens
but all things on earth also emit rays
themselves which is what leads to cause
and effect between terrestrial objects
and phenomena so the rays come from the
heavenly bodies from the beginning but
that those rays also stay within the
world so that objects in the terrestrial
world have rays themselves which they
omit and which also causes cause and
effect
different actions produce different rays
and different amounts of rays a magical
action can capture the powers of rays
vocal incantations produce rays which is
how words and phrases can have magical
effects
perhaps controversially to some this is
also how prayers work toward kindy when
praying one is producing race which can
have an effect on one's life he also
points out that animal sacrifice in
particular produces an explosion of race
and is thus the most effective way of
producing magical results without
necessarily condoning the practice
this idea of these stellar rays would
become very influential not only in
later islamic astrology but also in
europe as well even today there are
remnants of this kind of idea we often
hear people talk about energies that
exist everywhere and affects things
around us and hindi is those of course a
hugely important figure in intellectual
history even if most people probably
don't realize it but why were scholars
like al kindy and abu masha writing
these things and creating these theories
about astrology well one of the primary
reasons was to legitimize astrology as a
practice by showing the way that the
stars and heavenly bodies had an
influence on earth through things like
the rays al kindy was trying to show
that this was a completely legitimate
natural science if all these things
could be explained naturally like that
there were now no difference between
using the astral rays for a magical
practice than of giving medicine to a
patient
by making astrology a natural science
they were trying to legitimize it to its
critics in some circles and times this
was successful in others it wasn't as we
saw in the beginning
and one of the things that the critics
would often point to was precisely the
way that the astrologers gave causal
power to the planets and stars powers
that according to them should only be
attributed to god and this was actually
quite a heated debate even before the
islamic period did the heavenly bodies
have actual causal powers in themselves
that is did they actually cause the
things to happen on earth or were they
just indications or signs of things that
were caused by something higher earlier
platonic philosophers like plutinus and
some of his followers like porphyry had
argued that these stars were simply
signs that could be read but that they
had no direct causal powers in
themselves others disagreed
islamic thinkers like al-kindi and abu
masad seemed to have taken a kind of
middle position in the case of al-qindi
he argued that these stars and planets
were indeed effective causes of things
on earth but he was a muslim after all
and thus is a strict monotheist
to him god is always the ultimate power
and cause of all things so the heavenly
bodies are from his perspective only
secondary causes they are the tools with
which god makes things happen on earth
powerful in themselves but only insofar
as they are given that power by god he
imagines someone shooting an arrow to
hit a deer for example the arrow flying
in the air is the heavenly bodies but
the shooter is god so the arrow
obviously has an effect once it hits the
targets but that effect is ultimately
caused by god shooting it to begin with
abu mashad on the other hand doesn't
seem as clear on the matter he
definitely attributes causal powers to
the stars and planets in a direct way
abu mashad al balhi was a persian
astrologer living contemporarily with al
kindy and the two seem to have
interacted
he is often remembered as the most
important astrologer of the early
islamic world and also worked in baghdad
under abbasid patronage he didn't speak
about the stellar rays of al-qindi but
also theorized in his own way about the
ways that the heavens influenced things
on earth and the four elements
in his works most famously perhaps the
kitab al muthkalet kibir the great
introduction he attempts to justify
astrology as a legitimate science and as
a companion science to medicine
according to abumasha the heavenly
bodies have an effect through the heat
that they emit the heat that the planets
emit affect the elements in the
terrestrial world and causes change to
happen furthermore on a more particular
level this happens in two ways in the
words of lyanna saif again quote
according to abu mashad the celestial
bodies act as causes in two interrelated
ways
they unite form with matter and they are
responsible for the union and harmony
between the body and the vital and
rational souls as a result of this
action a connection between the heaven
and earth exists and the elements below
move transform and experience generation
and corruption
so how was astrology employed in
practice
as we have seen in a lot of ways it was
always a very significant form of
divination of foretelling future events
or of things like
reading your horoscope for example this
means that it has always been very
important and appealing to those in
power caliphs of the abbasid dynasty
later sultans and kings of various
dynasties across the islamic world would
all employ astrologers to help them in
strategy foretell the outcome of things
or to bring them luck he was also of
course a very central part of the
practical art of magic as we saw earlier
this becomes especially apparent in a
work like the massively important book
of magic called the rayatul hakim or the
goal of the sage thoughts have been
written by the andalusian muslim by even
class
this work more famously known by its
later translated latin title the
pikatrix is one of the most influential
work of occult sciences in history both
in the islamic world and in european
contexts
we're going to dedicate a full episode
to this work later this year but
important for us today is that it takes
a lot of the ideas presented by figures
like al kindy and abu mashar synthesizes
them and with other currents as well and
creates a very practical manual for how
to practice astral magic the reatel
hakeem features detailed instructions on
how to create talismans for different
purposes if you want to make this and
that person fall in love do these
particular things while the planets are
in this particular alignment
if you want to destroy an entire town do
this and that in connection to this
position of the moon and many such
things the stars planets and heavens
generally are at the center of the
practices described in the pika tricks
much of which can be traced back to
figures like el kindy the rayatal hakim
or pikatrix in latin form would go on to
become one of the most important perhaps
the most important grimoire in europe
during later periods and had an enormous
impact on astrologers in the later
medieval and modern periods
it is still widely read and influential
to western esotericism and occultism
so we can see how the islamic
astrologers have been directly
influential to developments in western
esotericism and astrology both directly
through translations of abu mashar's
work like his great introduction as well
as al-quindi's on the stellar race but
also indirectly through the huge
importance and influence of the pikatrix
which in itself featured many of the
ideas and traditions developed by the
earlier islamic philosophers picking up
from this point in particular my good
friend dr angela puka will be making a
companion video to this one where she
explores astrology in western
esotericism in particular and if you
watch that video you will be able to see
how many of these early islamic thinkers
are hugely influential on the tradition
of western esotericism and astrology in
the more western world as well so
definitely go check out that video dr
puka is a phd and university lecturer in
religious studies and her youtube
channel called angela symposium is
focused on the academic study of magic
esotericism witchcraft paganism and all
other occult topics so i highly
recommend that channel she's an amazing
scholar and her videos are really
informative
for now i hope this has been an
informative and interesting introduction
to astrology in the islamic world
particularly as it developed in the
earliest periods as well as how those
early thinkers have influenced some of
the currents in later western
esotericism and astrology in the western
world as well we will have an
opportunity later on to discuss the more
later developments of astrology in the
islamic world as well as to focus on
specific things like particular
grimoires like the raya talakim or the
shams and marif as well as subjects like
alchemy and the science of letters
it's gonna get weird but truly
fascinating i'll see you next time
[Music]
you